[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAY TSANG: Thanks,
everyone, for being here.
And hopefully everyone
had a great conference.
I know that we went
through a lot of things
for the past couple of days.
My name is Ray.
I'm a developer advocate for
the Google Cloud platform.
One of my job is to bring
some of the best technologies
that Google has to
offer, both the products
and the open source projects
to the Java developers
all over the world.
And I love to make that
Java experience the best
experience for the
Java developers
where you're using Google Cloud
platform also Java Champion.
And if you have any questions,
please please contact me
on Twitter @saturnism.
And today we have a
special guest as well.
Josh, go for it.
JOSH LONG: Hi, everybody.
My name is Josh Long.
I'm a spring developer
advocate on the spring team.
And I'm an open source
engineer and a contributor.
I have the dubious distinction
in my 10 plus years
contributing to the various
spring projects of being
the number one, top-ranked,
most visible, most prolific,
most highly lauded, most
acclaimed contributor--
[CLEARS THROAT]
--of bugs, but still
number one, number one,
number one to all the projects
to which I'm a contributor.
There is that.
I do training videos.
I do books.
I just finished my
latest and greatest book
called "Cloud
Native Java," which
is all about how to build
applications that survive
and thrive in the cloud in
terms of Java and Spring Boot,
and Spring Cloud,
and Cloud Foundry,
and all these other
great technologies.
And the book is something
about which I'm very proud.
It's a book about how to
build applications that do
the right thing in the cloud.
And it did take a little longer
than we expected it might take.
It did take just
a little longer.
We thought, given our privileged
position within the community,
we'd have it done
within six months.
No problem.
But it did, in point of
fact, take just a little--
it took a little--
it took two years all right.
Took two years to get
this dumb book out.
And there's a big
reason for that, right?
And I lay the blame for
that tardiness, that
delay at the feet of that
intense deliberations that
went on between
us-- the author team
and the publisher, O'Reilly.
We spent an extra
18 months deciding
upon the animal for the cover.
Now anybody who knows
anything about O'Reilly books
knows that it doesn't all that
much matter what's in the book
proper.
It has everything to do with
what's on the animal, what's
the animal.
So we eventually settled
upon a blue-eared kingfisher.
It's a bird that is indigenous
or native to the Indonesian
Java islands.
It's a bird that is indigenous
or native to the Indonesian
Java islands.
And birds fly, yes,
through the clouds.
So it's a bird that
is native to Java
that flies through the clouds.
It's a cloud native Java bird.
It's a bird-- never mind.
It'll come.
[LAUGHTER]
It will come.
Give it time.
And at Pivotal I am a--
just like my friend, Ray, here--
I'm a Java Champion.
And we care about
helping developers.
RAY TSANG: Yup.
So as you may have probably seen
for the past couple of days,
we have so many
different services
and products you can
actually consume and use.
We have everything from
compute, run your application,
to services for machine
running to big data
processing, all of these things.
One of our goals is actually
to make this the easiest
things to access
for Java developers
and also for Spring
developers as well.
So one of the goals
that we had was
to provide one of the best
integrations for spring
and Spring Boot to consume
and use GCP services.
And we actually worked
really hard and together
between Google engineers
and Pivotal engineers
to provide this
new project, which
is called Spring Cloud GCP.
It is an open source project.
You can find it on the
Spring Cloud organization
on the GitHub repository.
And we worked really
hard to make sure
that it is [INAUDIBLE] for
the Spring Boot development.
And it's easy to use.
And why don't we
just get started
and show you what we got?
JOSH LONG: I think we should.
All right.
I'll take the lead if you
don't mind, my friend.
So--
RAY TSANG: Go for it.
JOSH LONG: Let's-- we're going
to build a new application
today.
And we're going to do so
at my second favorite place
on the internet.
My first favorite place on
the internet, of course,
is production.
I love production.
You should love production.
You should go as early
and often as possible.
Bring the kids.
Bring the family.
The weather's amazing.
It's the happiest
place on earth.
It's better than Disneyland.
But if you haven't
been to production,
then you can begin your journey
here at start.spring.io.
If you need inspiration
in the early morning
before a cup of tea or
coffee, start.spring.io.
If your children are
restless and can't sleep,
start.spring.io.
And if you suffer
from indigestion
after a long night of alcohol
abuse and PHP, start.spring.io.
So we're going to build a new
service called the reservation
hyphen service.
And this service is going to
take advantage of Spring's web
support.
We're going to take advantage
of the JDBC and MySQL support.
And so we've got that, JDBC.
We're going to use
actuator for observability.
We're going to use Lombok to
make Java just a little bit
less like Java, a little bit
less tedious, if you will.
There's a number of other
supported languages here,
not the least of
which is Kotlin.
But you can also choose Groovy.
We're going to choose--
what else do we need, my friend?
RAY TSANG: Well, we are going
to be running this application
and using GCP services.
So you can actually add--
JOSH LONG: There we are.
RAY TSANG: GCP support as well.
Yep.
JOSH LONG: All right.
And I think that's it.
We need Web, MySQL,
JDBC, Actuator, Lombok--
RAY TSANG: Spring data REST.
JOSH LONG: Data
REST repositories.
Yup.
There we are.
So that's a number of
selections for now.
That'll get us started.
We'll add some more things
as we need to iteratively.
Let's hit Generate.
And that'll give
us this new project
that I'm going to
open up in my IDE.
So here I am in the
downloads directory.
I'm going to unzip and open.
That's a little alias that
just does that for me.
I'm going to open
this up in my IDE.
And any IDE will work just fine.
I'm using IntelliJ.
How many of you
are using IntelliJ?
I'm just curious.
How many of you use Eclipse?
Also good stuff.
Hot Sauce.
How about NetBeans?
NetBeans?
Emax?
Very cool.
Awesome.
So we have a number
of options here.
We're going to put a
simple application.
And we're going
to start this off
with an enterprising use
case, an application that's
talking to a SQL database.
Now, can you see that font?
That should be legible, yeah?
We're good?
OK.
So we're going to talk
to an application that
has some SQL in it.
And to do so, we're going to
take data out of a database,
read the data into
DTOs, that we're
going to modify or manager
here on the client.
So we're going to have
a DTO, if you will,
that just reads data
and prints the data out.
So we have a simple
object with two fields.
And I'm going to use Lombok.
Lombok is this compile
time annotation processor
that'll synthesize things
like the getters, the setter,
the two string, the
constructors, et cetera.
It'll do all that stuff for
me through the compile time--
these annotations.
Now, I'm going to write a thing.
I'm going to write
an object that's
going to run when the
application starts up.
And so in order for it to run
when the application starts up,
I want Spring, which is my
framework that I'm using here,
to call this run method.
It's good to see that my
object, which I've annotated
with that component, implements
the application runner
interface.
And it's going to
give me an opportunity
to do whatever I want when
the application starts up,
passing in the public static
void main string arguments
array.
In that object,
I'm telling Spring
to inject the collaborating
object, this JDBC template,
which an object I can use to
talk to SQL-based databases.
And here, I'm going to say,
this.JDBCTemplate.query, select
all from reservations.
And when I get the
results back I'm
going to map each row that comes
back into an entity of type
reservation.
So there we are.
There's my application.
And I'm going to say for
each result set row, RS,
let's get the IDE and
the reservation name
and turn it into
a new reservation.
So RS dot get string
reservation name.
So there's our entity.
And now of course, this
can be better written
with Lambdas and Java 8.
There we are.
Now that API, the API we're
using, the JDBC template,
is very powerful.
It's been in Spring
since 2001 or so.
So it's been around forever.
And you'll see here in the
comments, our very own Thomas
Risberg, among many others.
Thomas Risberg was
a main contributor
to this class over a
long period of time.
And the result of this is a
collection of reservations.
So I'm going to
say query.ForEach,
and I'm going to print
out the results, so
system out print line.
And there we are.
There is my result.
And when this
application starts up,
I'm going to need to have a
SQL schema that I can use.
And I'm going to need to
have some sample data.
So I'm going to tell
Spring Boot to initialize
the database by running the
script called schema.sql.
I'm going to create a
table called Reservations
when the application starts up.
And I'm going to initialize it.
I'm going say,
you're going to have
an IDE that's going
to be big int,
not null, auto
increment, primary key.
And I'll have a field
called Reservation Name--
Reservation Name.
It's going to be var
char 225, not null.
Now, I want to be
able to delete this.
I want to make sure I delete it
when the application starts up
if it already exists.
So I'm going to say DROP
TABLE if exists Reservations.
So there we go.
That's going to create
the schema idempotently.
And then I'm going to
now initialize some data.
So I'm going to say data.sql.
And here, I'm going to insert
some records into my database
so we have something
with which to work.
So insert into Reservations
reservation name, values, Josh,
I'm going to have Ray.
And we'll have some
of our friends.
There we go.
So there are a few of our
friends in the application.
So now we have four
records that we're
going to write when the
application starts up.
I need to tell Spring to run
this script when it starts up.
I need to tell it to run
this script when it runs up.
So I'm going to say,
initialization mode
equals always.
And there we have it.
Then I'm done, right?
I don't have to
do anything else.
I mean, I'm missing one
little thing it occurs to me.
I'm missing--
RAY TSANG: Where's
your database?
JOSH LONG: Yeah.
Well, I hadn't really
gotten around to that, man.
RAY TSANG: Wait, you don't
have any on your local machine?
JOSH LONG: .
No
RAY TSANG: That's OK.
But you do have a
Google Cloud Project?
JOSH LONG: I do.
RAY TSANG: All right.
Let's go there and check it out.
JOSH LONG: OK so.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, there we go.
JOSH LONG: Cloud.console--
RAY TSANG: Yeah,
Console.Cloud.google.com
JOSH LONG: OK.
Yeah very cool.
RAY TSANG: So you
are in the project.
Why don't we go
and find CloudSQL?
So you do have a CloudSQL
instance, which is great.
This is our managed
SQL database.
So you can actually
create a database
that has either MySQL
or a [? PostgreSQL. ?]
Why don't we click into it?
Now, there are many different
ways for you to connect.
One of the ways that you can do
it by using the IP address down
there.
But you don't really want
to do that because that
is a public IP.
So rather than doing
that, one of the best way
to connect to it is by use
the instance connection name.
And in order for
you to use that,
what happens behind
the scenes, it's
going to create a new JDBC
URL that actually configures
a special SSL socket factory
that will actually interchange
the certificate for you
in order to establish
your secure connection
to the back end database.
Now, in order for you to
have that functionality,
one of the easiest
way is actually
by using our starter that we
built for this Spring Cloud GCP
project.
And once you have the starter
in the dependency tree,
then you can actually
just configure it.
So there should
be a configuration
called the instance connection
name that you can refer to.
Yeah, there we go,
says [INAUDIBLE]..
And then you got to specify
the database as well, which
is the one that you created.
I think it's-- if you go up,
if you go to databases right
there, that actually show
you the database you have
in the instance and
its code reservations.
JOSH LONG: So that
should work, right?
I mean that should be
actually all I need.
RAY TSANG: I think
that's it, yeah.
JOSH LONG: OK
let's give it a go.
Let's see what happens.
RAY TSANG: You want
to try it out live?
JOSH LONG: What could go wrong?
RAY TSANG: What could go wrong?
Who here thinks
this will just work?
Oh wow, nobody.
JOSH LONG: No confidence at all.
RAY TSANG: No?
Yeah, exactly.
Well let's take a look.
So it is connect.
It is running.
And oh my goodness, did you
see that just that scroll by?
There it is.
JOSH LONG: It worked.
Of course it worked.
It's a demo.
[CROWD LAUGHS]
What were you expecting instead?
We have this, but let's
focus on this for a second.
Notice that we have all these
different connections here.
All these different
connections, this application
has got a whole
bunch of connections
to talk to the database.
So we can tune the
connectivity parameters here
in the same way we would do
anything else by specifying
properties on Spring Boot's
data source configuration.
Here I'm going to say I want to
have a maximum of two threads.
So when that's
going to restart, we
should see that we'll have
considerably less output
on the console when the
application starts up.
But that is working.
We're actually talking to
a database in the cloud.
We can see that right?
Does everybody see that here?
RAY TSANG: Not from here.
JOSH LONG: Not from here, no?
So there we go.
We've got the data.
We've got the database.
We've got the auto-incremented
ID and all that stuff that's
been done for us.
That's working just fine.
I'm a big fan of MySQL.
But I hear that even Google
moved away from MySQL
for AdWords years ago.
They had global
consistency problems.
They wanted to
make sure they had
data that was visible across all
their data centers across all
over the world.
And they wanted to have
externally consistent
distributed transactions.
So I heard that they
had this thing called
Spanner, which sounds
like a really smart idea.
But as I understand it,
I need atomic clocks
and GPS receivers.
And that sounds like a real--
doesn't sound like
something I want to manage.
What can we do?
RAY TSANG: So we actually have
Spanner, the database that
is globally visible,
globally distributed,
strongly consistent,
relational database that you
can use on the cloud, on GCP.
It's Cloud Spanner.
Now to use Cloud
Spanner, sometimes you
may have to use the API.
But what we have done
with Spring Cloud GCP
is to actually integrate
this with Spring Cloud Data,
or Spring Data for Spanner.
So one of the things
that we can do
is actually why don't we go
ahead and open up the palm.xml.
And so what I'm going
to do is to just get rid
of some of these MySQL stuff.
So I'm going to say--
there we go.
Maybe let me get
rid of that for now.
And then the JDBC
starter, we don't
need that for the next one.
And I do need to change out
the starter right there.
Wait, what happened?
JOSH LONG: You
control-clicked on something.
RAY TSANG: Oh, I did.
Man, your keyboard
is so hard to use.
There we go.
So where did it go?
Let me open this
up again, palm.xml.
So to use Spring Data,
I'm going to switch out
this [INAUDIBLE] right here.
I'm just going to use
Starter Data and Spanner.
Now, this starter is actually
in a newer version of the Spring
Cloud GCP Project.
So I'm just going to update
the project to 1.1.0.
This is something you can
actually try today as well.
And that should bring in
the right dependencies.
Once we have that done, I can
go back to this application.
I can go back to this POJO.
And I can actually just start to
map this POJO into the Spanner
tables.
So what that will
allow you to do
is to not having to use the raw
APIs when you don't actually
need to.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is to just map it
to a Spanner table
with the @table annotation.
For the primary keys, we can use
the Spring ID annotation here.
But because Spanner
may actually require
you to use a composite key for
a parent-children relationships,
because we want you
to use composite keys
with multiple primary keys that
has interleaving in between,
so we actually have an
additional annotation here
for a primary key.
With a distributed
database, because once you
shard the data globally,
one of the things
that we don't want
you to do is to use
a monotonically increasing ID.
So that traditional long
IDs you probably don't want
to use anymore.
And what we're going
to use is you're
going to be using a
randomly-generated UUID
instead.
And of course, for
the columns, we
can map this to a column on
the Spanner table as well.
But sometimes the name doesn't
match the name of the field,
so we can also use
the annotation here.
For example, we can call
it reservation_name.
And that's really it.
Now, we actually have to go and
create the Spanner database.
So I'm going to go back
to the console here.
I'm going to go and just go
and find Spanner the product--
oh, no, not that one.
There we go, Spanner.
And let's see if we can find it.
There we go.
So we have no Spanner
instances here.
I'm just going to go ahead
and create one really, really
quickly.
I'm going to call it
reservations demo.
And that's going to
give you an instance ID.
Here you have the
options of whether you
want a global deployment or
multi-regional deployment,
or regional deployment.
I'm just going to be
on the safe side here.
I'm going to use a
small deployment here
with US-Central1.
And then you can select the
number of nodes that you want.
Now, Spanner is
horizontally scalable.
Basically each node, there's
a little guidance here
that tells you how much
load each of that nodes
can actually handle.
So a node can go up to 10,000
QPS for that reads and 2,000
QPS for the write.
If you need more,
you just increase
the number of the nodes.
And I'm just now go ahead
and create this new instance.
And once I get there,
it's going to ask
me to create a new database.
So within the instance, I can
create multiple databases.
I'm just going to create a new
database called reservations
similar to what Josh has done.
And we have this nice
UI that you can actually
use to create the table.
I'm going to call it
"reservation table."
If I don't make
any mistakes, I'm
going to create a new ID field
here with a string as the type.
There we go.
And UUID has 36 characters, so
that's what I'm going to use.
And let me just scroll down
and make this not null.
And I'm going to go ahead
and create another ID that is
called the "reservation name."
Is that right?
Yeah.
And there's a string
as well, not null.
And then I can, of
course, continue and just
make sure I have
the primary key.
And click on Create.
JOSH LONG: Hey, Ray.
RAY TSANG: And
that should do it.
Yep.
JOSH LONG: Real developers
don't use user interfaces.
What's this about, man?
RAY TSANG: What?
JOSH LONG: Can I use text?
Can I use a console?
RAY TSANG: Well,
actually you can.
So up here, you can
actually edit as text,
so we can actually show
you the actual DDL that's
necessary to create this table.
And you can run this DDL
against a Spanner database
from a script or from
an API when you're
provisioning a new database.
JOSH LONG: OK.
RAY TSANG: So I'm going
to go ahead and create it.
And while it's creating--
and that's done.
Reservations, I got
everything right?
All right, very cool.
So to access this database, I'm
going to be using Spring Data.
Spring Data is
really, really cool.
So rather than writing a
lot of the boilerplate code,
all I'm going to do is to
create new interface called
"reservation
repository," ready to go.
I'm going to extend the
paging and sorting repository
here for the entity
type of reservation
and the key type of a string.
There we go.
Oops!
Not that string, wrong string.
JOSH LONG: Where did
that even comes from?
RAY TSANG: I do not know.
There you go.
So there we go.
And that is going to give you
CRUD access to the Spanner
database that has
pagination support
and sorting support
just like that.
JOSH LONG: So
that's an interface.
Spring Data will automatically
provide an object
at runtime that implements
interface and provides
those methods for you.
RAY TSANG: Yep.
So what I'm going to do
then is to just show you
how this repository work.
I'm going to create
a Spanner runner that
will implement the application
runner as well, just like that.
And I need to get used
to Josh's keyboard
here with the implementation.
And what I'm going to do is to
just inject the repository in,
so I'm going to do private
[? fino. ?] What is it called?
Reservation repository.
I'm going to call it Ripple.
And then, of course, I need to
get this into the constructor.
So there we go.
Once I have the
repository, I can
do all of the basic operations.
So for example, I can
delete all the records
from the Spanner
database if I want to
on every startup
of the application.
You shouldn't do it, but I'm
going to do it for the demo.
And then I'm going to
also do a string here
of maybe a few names.
I'm going to say Josh--
JOSH LONG: Hi.
RAY TSANG: --Ray and my
awesome coworker Jisha as well.
And for each of the
names that we got,
I'm going to do a
map function here.
And I'm going to create the new
reservation object like that.
And because we need to
generate this UUID string,
I'm just going to generate the
UUID through random UUID two
string.
And then I'm going
to pass the name in.
And then for every one of these
reservation that we created,
I'm just going to map it
to the repo save method.
So this go to save the data
into the Spanner repository.
And then for each
of them, I'm going
to use my favorite
logger in production,
which is System.out.println.
is what we do all the time.
All right, very cool.
And finally, the last
piece of the puzzle
is, well, I'm going to
you just do the control.
Why?
Is that right?
JOSH LONG: Yep, that'll work.
RAY TSANG: There
goes the JDBC stuff.
And we need to get rid
of this import on the top
as well because I
remove that dependency.
So let me give of that.
And final piece of the
puzzle is to actually
connect to the Spanner
database properly.
So I'm going to, again,
get rid of these things.
And since I pulled in
the Spanner starter
for Spring Data,
what I can do is
to refer it to this
Spanner instance ID, which
was Reservations-Demo.
And then, of course,
I need to specify
the database I'm
trying to connect to,
which is just Reservations.
And all of these
should just connect up
to Spanner with CRUD
access with object mapping.
And I'm not very convinced that
this is just going to work.
Is it that simple?
JOSH LONG: It should be.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
It's hard to follow
right after you do.
So I'm going to stop and rerun.
And let's see if
this actually works.
Ooh, this is really scary.
So behind the scenes, we are
establishing the authentication
and connecting through Spanner.
And this is trying to connect it
via our conference Wi-Fi here.
And there you go.
There is a Reservation
objects that is actually
being stored in Spanner.
Just to prove to you
I didn't fake this,
I'm going to go back to the
database I just created.
I'm going to go to
the Reservation table,
and we're going to
go through the data.
Here you can actually browse.
And there we go.
We got the data that
we just created.
Now, of course, Spring Data
can do much, much more.
If you want to create
a service, I actually
exposed the Spanner data
via a RESTful interface.
What I can do is to go back
to the repository here.
And I just need to add
an annotation here called
the REST Repository.
There we go.
Where is it?
There we go, Repository
REST Resource.
Yeah.
So just by adding
this one annotation,
all of the CRUD
functionalities can be exposed
via a RESTful interface.
I'm going to do another reload
here, just stop and run.
And it's going to
restart the application.
Again, reestablish the
connection to Spanner,
and then expose this
on the CRUD interface.
I'm just going to open
up the terminal here.
Hopefully you can see it.
I'm going to do
curl localhost:8080.
So this is what we
are connected to.
And you can see that we have an
endpoint that is automatically
exposed.
And we can go to
Reservations endpoint.
And of course, I should be able
to see all the Spanner data
that I actually
configured to map.
Now, this is CRUD.
What that means is you can
also post into this endpoint.
And you will save the data to
Spanner in a global fashion.
JOSH LONG: That's awesome!
So now we have highly available,
consistent, globally-available,
state of persistence
and storage.
I can build the ultimate
cat picture website.
This is the kind of technology
that we need in 2018.
This is what we're here for.
This is what we're
bringing to bear
a whole warehouse
full of computers
is to be able to build cat
picture websites at scale.
So I know that as
the site scales out,
there is going to
be more people that
are going to connect to it.
I'm going to have more services.
Certainly, this is
just the beginning
of a long and wonderful
journey to production.
And we'll going to have
other microservices that are
going to talk to each other.
As we add more
users to the system,
they lose the system
with more traffic,
we're going to see more
people hitting the surface.
And we're going to want
to know how requests flow
from one node to
another in the system,
how they move from one
microservice to another.
And this is a very
common use case,
especially as you start to
conduct more and more data
over the wire using
microservices.
You need to be
able to understand
where something happened.
You've heard it said before
that moving to microservices
is like making every production
incident a murder mystery.
We have to figure
out what happened.
We need to understand
where latency is.
We need to find out
where there's a problem.
And then one way to do this
is to use distributed tracing
as popularized fittingly by
the Dapper Paper published
by Google back in 2011.
Distributed chasing in
theory is very simple.
For every request that
enters or exits a system,
at every ingress or
egress in the system,
we have a unique ID that
gets added to the message
if it's not there already.
And it gets perpetuated
if it is there.
So we take a message,
look at the unique ID,
and then we make sure that we
send another outgoing message,
we add that same ID.
That correlation ID
allows us to then
record the receipt
of that message
and then see where that
message has been later on.
We can publish
information about where
that message has been later on.
In theory, it's very simple.
But imagine all the things you
have to do to instrument all
your code to be aware of this.
Well, in Spring
Cloud, we have an SPI
called Spring Cloud Sleuth--
sleuth, like a detective,
like a Sherlock Holmes.
Spring Cloud Sleuth is a
distributed tracing SPI.
And there are different
implementations
of which I think the Spring
Cloud, GCP, Google Cloud Stack
Trace--
Stackdriver Trace implementation
is one of the best.
So we're going to use that
here for our application.
I need to go to my build and add
Spring Cloud GCP Starter Trace.
And we'll add the
org.springframework.cloud
dependencies as before.
I did-- What is SADIK Framework?
RAY TSANG: Yeah, I know.
There we go.
JOSH LONG: Ante Maria.
All right, we're almost
there, almost there.
Look at that.
OK.
So we've got now Spring
Cloud GCP Starter Trace.
That's on the console.
It's on a build.
That's really all I need to do.
But remember, it's going to
plug into Spring Cloud Sleuth.
By default, Spring Cloud
Sleuth captures one out
of every 10 request
because you're not
going to see-- you're
not going to need
to see every single
request in order
to understand what's happened.
Remember, this is all
about online telemetry,
what's happening right now.
And you'll see the emergent
behavior of your system
in the patterns.
You don't need to
and nor should you
want to capture every single
request of every single node
in the logging system.
Instead, it's by
default ratcheted down
to one out of 10, or 0.1.
But we're going to
ratchet it up to 1.0
so that we can,
in our stage demo
here, see everything quickly.
Now, I'm going to drive some
traffic to this endpoint using
a trace runner,
which is just going
to be a thing that implements
an application runner.
And we'll use this Spring
Framework REST template.
Now, the REST template is
another template object
like the JDBC template
that we looked
at earlier that allows us
to make easy REST calls,
HTTP calls to other services.
And I'm going to factory
an instance of that bean.
I'm going to tell Spring
to vend an instance
of that bean of this object
in this factory method.
So Spring's going
to see this bean.
And it's going to see
that we have Spring Cloud
Sleuth on the class path.
It's going to instrument this
client, this HTTP client,
with an interceptor that is
aware of outgoing requests.
So now I can say, for int i
equal 0, i is less than 10,
i++.
And then I'm just
going to say this,
dot REST Template dot get for
entity HTTP localhost 8080
forward slash Reservation.
So I'm going to call
myself basically.
And I'm going to tell
Spring Cloud Sleuth--
I'm going to tell the
REST template rather,
to give me a payload
of type string back.
So the result will be this here.
And I'm just going
to log that out.
System out result,
result, like so.
Now, that's going to be fine.
But remember, we're
making requests
from a service on the
command line basically.
When the application
starts up, there's
no trace context at the moment.
So I'm going to simulate
a trace context.
Normally you'd have that.
If you had one microservice
with a REST API calling another,
you'd see that.
But we don't have that here.
So I'm going to tell Spring
Cloud Sleuth to initiate
a span trace client.
In tracing parlance,
you have the trace,
which is the aggregate journey
of all the requests going
from A to Z. From A to B to C to
D, that whole thing is called--
it's just one trace.
You have one trace ID.
Each hop in the journey,
each leg of the journey,
is called a span.
So you have multiple span
IDs and one trace ID.
So there we go.
I started the application.
I made a number of
different requests.
You can that all here
reflected in the console.
Now, if we go back to
Google Cloud-- oops,
I'm going to search for it.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, there you go.
JOSH LONG: Trace, awesome.
Trace list.
RAY TSANG: Sure that works too.
JOSH LONG: Deep dive.
So you can see that
I've got one request.
Or I've got an
overarching request
that starts with
that client, and then
a number of subordinate
requests that were
executed in successive order.
So if I click on this, I can
the top trace client thing.
It took 1.7 seconds--
1.7 seconds to make
all those requests.
And then I can see pairs.
Here's the outgoing thing and
the response, outgoing thing
and response.
If I look at that, I can see
the timestamps, the headers,
the context about the
request, what endpoint it hit.
And if I had enabled
Stackdriver Trace logging,
then I would see correlated
logging here as well.
I'd see view logs.
So here we have all that on
the console readily available
just for our dependency
in the application.
Now that said, I've got tracing.
And it's working just fine.
Now I have observability.
I can see more or
less what's happening
in the system at runtime.
Now, I can feel a little
bit more confident
when I want to integrate this
with other services out there.
Globally-consistent
and globally-available
though Spanner is,
the last thing I want
is to hand out
credentials to partners
and other people that
depend upon my API for them
to get my data.
Instead, I'd much prefer
to broadcast that data
so that they can consume
it in their applications.
And here, this is a natural case
for messaging or integration.
There's a lot of good
options out there.
I could, were I so inclined,
stand up an Apache Kafka
cluster certainly.
But there's a very nice
choice here in Google Cloud
called Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
So I'm going to
use that instead.
And it's fairly straightforward.
We're going to go to
our build, and we're
going to add Spring Cloud
GCP Starter Pub/Sub,
org.springframework.cloud.
And now, I'm going to
build a thing that's
going to start up and
produce some messages,
and another thing that's
going to start up and consume
the messages
Let's go to REST controller here
at REST controller-- producer
REST controller.
And whenever somebody
hits this endpoint--
we'll make it get because
no time for a post.
And we're going to say that we
want to send to void publish.
And we're going to use
the Pub/Sub template.
So I'm going to say private
final Pub/Sub template.
And the template I'll inject
into my constructor as normal.
And I'll say this dot
template dot publish.
I'm going to send it to a topic
called Reservations, which
I haven't yet initialized.
And we'll come back to that.
And the message I'll
send is "hello name."
And the name is
the path variable
here in the method definitions,
so path variable string name.
There we are.
And this returns a listenable
future of type string.
So I'm going actually assign
that result to my method here.
And I'll just tell Spring
to manage that for me.
So I'll say return
this dot that.
Now, that's my producer.
On the consumer side, I'm going
to have a consumer runner that
implements application runner.
And the consumer runner
is going to start up.
And it's going to take advantage
of the Pub/Sub template
here to subscribe.
So I'll say, at
subscribe in this method.
And I'll register
a message listener,
so this dot template
dot subscribe.
And I'm going to subscribe to
the Reservations subscription.
So these are not the same thing.
There's a decoupling
between the thing what
you pull for messages
and the thing that
actually takes incoming
messages, in just versus out,
whatever.
So we're going to
print out the message.
Received this message dot
get data dot two string UTF8.
And then we're going to
explicitly acknowledge
the consumption of
the message, otherwise
that message will get
read delivered later on.
So I'm going to take
care of that now.
Now, before we can run this
code, interesting though it is,
we need to actually configure
these topics and subscriptions
here in Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
So I'm going to go down
here to Pub/Sub down there.
Here we are.
And I'm going to go
to the Topics column.
And I'm going to
create a topic called
Reservations, which is what
we said we had, create that.
And then that's going to need
a corresponding subscription.
So I'll create a
new subscription.
And that's going to be called
Reservation Subscription.
And I'll hit Create.
With that in place,
I have everything
I need to be able to
run this application.
Let's go ahead and give it
a go and see what we get.
So now, once that's
up and running,
I can hit curl localhost:8080/p
ublish/GoogleNext.
Is that good?
RAY TSANG: Yeah, I think so.
JOSH LONG: Looks OK?
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
Is it running?
JOSH LONG: There we go.
We got a response.
RAY TSANG: Did you add the
component in for the runner?
JOSH LONG: Yeah, there
it is, consumer runner.
Did I misspell something?
Oh, I did misspell something.
It's, yeah, here.
I said reservations
subscriptions.
RAY TSANG: OK.
There we go.
JOSH LONG: Awkward,
very awkward.
Sorry about that.
RAY TSANG: That's not
too bad for just making
a simple mistake like that.
We all do that.
JOSH LONG: Well, that's awkward.
I could do better.
These cat picture websites
won't get to production
with that kind of sloppy coding.
So there we go.
Oh by the way, you saw
the missed message.
There's the message that I--
it's been
retroactively consumed.
Come on.
Oh dear.
RAY TSANG: Oh, there it is.
JOSH LONG: There's that.
There's hello next.
Now I'm going to send it again
because I've got it queued.
And we should see if we go
down here, there it is again.
RAY TSANG: That's not bad.
JOSH LONG: That's
not bad, not bad.
RAY TSANG: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
Now of course, we have a lot
of different functionalities
here that you can
actually use Spring with.
And if Spring has an
abstraction for it,
we would love to have some kind
of a nice layer underneath it
so that you can consume that
GCP services very easily.
We saw it for Spanner.
We actually have
other integrations
for configurations for
accessing cloud storage
so you can store as much
of the data as you want.
But if you don't have
that kind of abstraction,
if you want to use some
kind of API just out
of the box from Google Cloud,
you can actually do that too.
So for example,
there's no abstraction
to use a vision
API for that matter
to analyze the pictures
that you can upload.
So what I'm going to
do is to, for example,
consume the vision
API that we have.
So the first thing
that we need to do
is to actually
add the dependency
for using that client library.
And that's pretty easily done.
All I need to do
is come back here.
I'm going to use the Google
Cloud Vision API to do this.
So there we go--
vision, vision, yep.
And it's going to be
under com.googlecloud.
There we go.
And because all the
dependencies are
being managed by the
bomb, what that means
is that we managed all the
compatible versions for you,
so you don't have to explicitly
declare any versions here.
We will transitively
import anything
that's necessary in order
for this API to work.
So once I have
this API imported,
then I can go ahead
and use screen
to potentially factory a client.
So I'm going to go back here.
And I'm going to use the
bean annotation here.
I'm going to produce a
image annotator client.
This is the client I need to
use to talk to the vision API.
So we're going to call it
the image annotation client.
And, of course, I can go ahead
and return this client as is.
But our starter actually can
figure out the environment
that you're running in.
And because we have
Google Apps Engine,
we've got Kubernetes
Engine where
we've got local
environments, you
might be running this
on-prem for that matter.
So what we do is
we automatically
try to understand what
credentials we can use,
and then we'll give you this
thing called the Credentials
Provider so that you can use
it to bootstrap your client
libraries with the
right credentials
that you configured for
your Spring application.
So I'm going to go
ahead and use these.
So I'm going to create a
Spring annotator client.
I'm going to make sure that
I've got the settings in there.
So this is only thing
that you have to do,
which is to use
the custom setting.
And I'm going to set the
credential provider just
like that.
It's going to add
an exception here.
Now, here's the thing.
This client is actually
a heavy client.
What that means is that we
try to keep the singleton.
And however it does
implement auto-closable.
What that means is that when the
Spring Boot application stops,
it will automatically
shut down the clients
and close all the connections
for you, so all of these things
we just worked.
Now to test this
thing out, I'm going
to also create a
little controller here
with the REST controller.
And I'm going to call it--
what should we call it?
Vision controller, how's that?
JOSH LONG: Yep.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
And I'm going to also--
for this one, we actually
need the post mapping,
so I'm going to call it vision.
So I'm going to try to
create a controller that I
can post a picture to.
And this is going
to return, let's say
it'll return a string.
I'm going to code this vision.
And I'm going to texting the
image upload as a parameter.
And to upload a file in
Spring, what you need to do
is to use a multi-part file.
And then I can
encode this image.
And that's it.
Now within here, I can also
go ahead and just inject
the client I just created.
So I'm going to private
final image annotator client.
There we go, and just
encode as the client.
And then, of course, I need to
get this into the constructor
as well.
There we go.
So from the client,
this old bootstrap,
this would just connect
up to the client--
sorry, for the vision API.
So what I can do is I can
go ahead and say client,
batch annotate the image.
And from here I need a list,
so we can use Collections dot
Singleton List.
And I need to pass in an
annotated image request,
so we got used [INAUDIBLE] here.
So what is in this request?
Well, we need to set the
image so this image will
have the bytes that
we just uploaded.
So we need to use
[INAUDIBLE] for the image.
And then we to, again,
set the content.
And that is a byte
string, which I'm
going to copy the bytes from
the image here to get bytes.
And that's pretty much it.
Now, there are many different
things that the vision
API can do for those.
For example, we can detect
what's inside the pictures.
We can actually extract text
from the imagery as well.
For every one of
those, we can just
add a feature
detection necessary for
this particular functionality.
So I'm going to go
ahead and just add
a feature that will
detect the labels,
so basically understanding
what is inside the picture.
So for that one, we're just
going to do label detection.
Of course, I can add more,
but that's pretty much it.
Now, this is going to
return the response.
I'm going to cover
it to a string.
And the image is going to
return this from the endpoint.
[INAUDIBLE]
JOSH LONG: The API just
rolls right off the tongue,
just very--
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
JOSH LONG: Me and
API, look at that.
It's always happening.
RAY TSANG: So let's see if
this actually will work.
So when this
application restarts,
we should have a vision endpoint
that will take a file upload.
But then for that,
we need a picture.
Do you have one?
JOSH LONG: I do, my friend.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
JOSH LONG: I've
got one right here.
RAY TSANG: Where do you have it?
JOSH LONG: Desktop/cat.
RAY TSANG: Of course.
JOSH LONG: So let's
look at the picture
so we know what we're
dealing with here.
It's a cat.
It's a cat, everybody.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, OK,
that's very nice.
Where did we get
that, on Wikipedia?
Is that right?
JOSH LONG: Yeah,
yeah, Wikipedia.
RAY TSANG: There we go.
JOSH LONG: So there you go.
So there's that.
So you know where to--
you know how to find it.
It's on the desktop there.
RAY TSANG: Yeah all right.
So there you are.
I'm going to just go
to the desktop here.
So that's easy.
I'm going to do
curl -F. So that is
going to you upload
the cat picture
and read from the file system.
And I'm going to post it
to the vision endpoint.
And of course, nobody
thinks this will just work.
Neither do I. But
oh, there we go.
So we just posted this
picture to the endpoint, which
then talked to the vision API.
That's Bootstrap by Spring.
And we can actually
see that it detected
that this is 99% a cat.
JOSH LONG: Yeah.
RAY TSANG: For sure.
Yeah.
It's a small to
medium-sized cat as well.
It's a cat-like mammal.
But I'm pretty sure it's a cat.
JOSH LONG: Yeah.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
JOSH LONG: Reasonably sure.
RAY TSANG: But we can also
see that the type of the cat
is 63% sure that it's
a European shorthair.
JOSH LONG: Right,
very interesting.
RAY TSANG: Yeah,
that was pretty cool.
JOSH LONG: Welll, right on.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
JOSH LONG: Our cat
picture website
is getting better and better.
Now (SIGHS) that's it.
I think we're missing
some important stuff.
We're missing some
important stuff.
First of all, this is an
enterprising cloud scale
kind of application.
It wouldn't be much
of an application
if we didn't have a suitable
[INAUDIBLE] banners.
So I'm going to make sure
that we address that right now
by adding a custom
banner.txt to my application.
Curl, Downloads,
Reservation Service,
Source, Main, Resources.
RAY TSANG: The
banner is this thing
that you see when you
start the application?
JOSH LONG: Yes.
We'll fix that right here.
RAY TSANG: OK.
JOSH LONG: So there we go.
We have good [INAUDIBLE]
banners already.
You can see in the application
when application starts up,
it says Spring right there.
It's very, very well done.
With that said, sometimes
people want to change it.
And that's OK.
If you want to change
it, you should feel free.
And I just showed you how.
I'm going to copy
that text file.
I've got this text file
here called banner.txt.
It's in my
application directory.
I'm going to now go to
the command line here, cd,
Downloads, Reservation Service,
mvn clean spring-boot:run.
Wait.
RAY TSANG: [CHUCKLES]
JOSH LONG: That not bad, right?
I control-c'd so we
can see the results.
There's [INAUDIBLE] cat.
Getting better, getting better.
I think that's a good thing,
a good feature, an addition
to our cloud data system.
That said, there
is one more thing
I'd like to talk about,
just one more thing.
You may have heard
about Knative.
Anybody here hear about
Knative in the last few days?
Yeah.
So we at Pivotal have
been working very closely
with our friends here at Google.
And we've got a
project called Riff.
Riff is for functions.
Get it?
It's a recursive
acronym friends.
Don't think too much about it.
Your head will explode.
It's for functions.
It's a function-as-a-service
platform built Knatively on top
of Knative.
And we debuted it the
day of the launch.
As soon as there was the ability
to talk about it publicly,
we released the version
that's built on top of it.
And that platform is available.
It's open source.
It's Apache 2 license.
You can download it
from ProjectRiff.io.
It's here.
And the docs, of
course, speak to how
to run it on local
machine, on minikube,
and on GKE, which is a nice
place to run your workloads.
So we have a GKE-based
riff on top of Knative.
I've got that running in
our Google Cloud account,
in my Google Cloud console
that's already deployed.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to show you how to deploy a
function-based application
to this runtime.
Now I've a couple
of examples here.
I'm going to go to my console.
Let's clean up some
of the noise here.
I've got a couple
of examples here.
I'm going go to my desktop.
And I'm going to look at the
bootable GCP Riff function.
And I'm going to open
this up in my IDE.
And this is a Spring Cloud
Function-based application.
Spring Cloud Function
is an abstraction
that allows you
to write functions
that work in an agnostic
way, independent
of any particular
function runtime.
So you can use--
what's that other
company in Seattle?
BWS, something like that.
That other company, they
have functions as well.
That other one-- the other
one in Redmond, they have one.
They have functions as well.
And of course, Riff
is a great choice.
Riff is, I think, the most
interesting option here.
We're going to open
up this Spring Cloud
Function-based application.
Normally in order to
run your functions
on these other platforms,
you need an adapter.
But you don't need
that for this.
So we have a very
simple function that
allows you to take a string--
it's literally just
a Java util function.
It's a Java 8 function API.
So we're going to say, given a
string in uppercase it, very,
very simple, trivial example.
And I simplified it down
to a lambda like this.
That's what that does.
And then I simplified
it yet again
to a method reference like that.
So very, very trivial, globally
scalable uppercase thing.
So there it is,
a simple example.
Now I'm going to deploy
this to Riff here.
I've got a little
script called Build.
And what build is going
to do is it's going to--
all this is to say I'm
going to build it, copy
the jar to the root of the
directory, check it in.
Then I'm going to get my
product ID for Google Cloud.
I've got a function name.
It's called Uppercase.
I'm going to delete
the function with Riff
if it's already existing.
And I'm going to
create a new one here
using Riff function
create Java, passing
in the name of the
function, pointing it
to the Git Repository because
that's the way Knative works.
It's one of the
ways Knative works.
We're pointing it to the
artifact, which, in this case,
is the jar.
And we're telling it to run
the handler called Uppercase.
Now Uppercase is the bean name
here, the Spring Cloud Function
bean.
And then we're
telling it to pull
the image from the
Google Container
Repository and the URL here.
So let's run this script.
It'll build.
And it'll deploy.
RAY TSANG: And actually, this
is actually a Spring Boot
application, right?
JOSH LONG: Yeah, it's a
Spring Boot application.
So everything we've
looked at, Spring Cloud,
GCP, all these things, you
can use within that function.
You can call them just like
you would any other Spring
Boot-based application.
Now, the application's
up and running.
We can see Riff Service List.
There's some-- Knative is
really new yet, my friends,
so there's some weirdness there.
But we see that
it's got Uppercase.
Now I'm going to say
kubectl get pods.
And we can see it
says Uppercase.
And we got zero out of three,
so get pods again, three out
of three.
So now, I'm going to run this
application using Riff run.
And this one's actually
fairly straightforward.
I'm going to say, I've got
a function named Uppercase.
I want to call the
function Gateway
using this command line.
But you could just
as easily call your--
get the URL, and the
host, and the port,
and then send a request to it
using curl or something else.
So I'm going to say, invoke
that function, passing
in a payload of
type hello Knative,
and get the result back.
So let's try this,
Riff Run, curl.
And there we go.
We got hello Knative.
Not bed, huh?
RAY TSANG: Yeah, I mean,
it's just Uppercase.
JOSH LONG: Huh?
RAY TSANG: It's very--
well, yeah, but it's
just uppercasing
a few strings, a few bytes.
I mean, is that what
you serverless for?
JOSH LONG: I've got a whole
warehouse full of computers.
If I want to just
uppercase strings,
that's what I want to do.
RAY TSANG: Well, can you
uppercase something else?
I mean, what else can
you do with this thing?
JOSH LONG: I can
uppercase a cat.
RAY TSANG: What?
JOSH LONG: Yeah.
RAY TSANG: The cat
picture that we just had?
JOSH LONG: Yeah.
RAY TSANG: Not the word cat,
but the actual picture of a cat.
JOSH LONG: Yeah.
RAY TSANG: How do you do that?
JOSH LONG: So we've got
another function here--
Desktop/uppercat.
RAY TSANG: Uppercat?
JOSH LONG: Yeah, totally
different application.
RAY TSANG: So what we do?
Is there a Uppercat
function that you
can code from the [? GEK? ?]
JOSH LONG: Yep.
And you can too.
So I'm going to build
it just as before.
We'll hit build.
So it's going deploy
just as before.
Get push, all that stuff.
RAY TSANG: So you're pushing
an Uppercat function.
JOSH LONG: Yeah.
Well, it's open source.
Others are free to use it.
So now if we go to
kubectl get pods,
we'll see that it's spinning
up, in it, three or four.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, still watch.
JOSH LONG: Watch, yeah.
RAY TSANG: There we go.
JOSH LONG: OK,
now we're cooking.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
OK, there we go, initializing.
Now what does it actually do?
How do you uppercase a cat.
I've never seen this before.
JOSH LONG: Well, it's
very sophisticated, Ray.
It's very complicated.
I'm not sure you'd
understand it.
RAY TSANG: No, I
don't think I would.
JOSH LONG: Don't worry.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
JOSH LONG: So it's deployed.
We've got this application.
We got three of three instances
of the Uppercat service
in the cloud.
Now, I'm going to invoke it.
So I'm going to say,
Riff run, same thing.
And here, what
I'm going to do is
I'm going to say Riff
servers invoke uppercat,
passing in header,
[? constant ?] type text plain.
I'm sending the bytes.
It doesn't really matter.
I'm sending the bytes
from this file cat.jpg.
It's the same one.
So open this.
There it is.
And that's the same cat.
it's the same cat, the poor cat.
Look at him.
Look at him, that
scaredy cat right there.
So I'm going to send
that cat into the cloud
and be transformed,
so cat Riff run.
And then once the
data comes out,
it going to be output to JSON.
There's a key in
the JSON called cat.
I'm going extract
that key with JQ,
and then pass it to [? bay ?]
64 to decode it, and then output
that to a JPEG file,
which I don't have here.
So there's no Uppercat JPEG.
All right, you ready?
I'm hoping this'll work.
RAY TSANG: I'm hoping
this works, too.
I don't know what magic
you have behind this.
JOSH LONG: We're done.
RAY TSANG: That was fast.
That was really, really fast.
JOSH LONG: The machine is done.
And there it is.
RAY TSANG: [LAUGHS]
JOSH LONG: All right, very good.
RAY TSANG: Very Nice, very nice.
That's how you uppercase a cat.
JOSH LONG: We did, yep.
RAY TSANG: I get it.
JOSH LONG: Now, we
have an application.
It's good.
But I think we do need one
more thing, one more thing.
I like the [INAUDIBLE]
that we looked at before.
RAY TSANG: OK, yeah.
JOSH LONG: But I do
want to improve upon it.
It's 2018, and if we
can uppercase cats,
we can do anything.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to replace the [INAUDIBLE]
one more time since we
have the time with an animated
GIF because that's how I roll.
So curl downloads
reservation service, source,
main, resources banner.gif.
RAY TSANG: Didn't you get
rid off the previous thing?
JOSH LONG: I think I do, yeah--
awkward-- banner.txt.
Now, back mvn clean
spring-boot:run.
Book I'm going to
try that again.
Huh?
RAY TSANG: [CHUCKLES] Very nice.
Very nice.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH LONG: Now.
RAY TSANG: It does take a few
seconds to start, doesn't it?
JOSH LONG: Yeah, I know it
takes 30 seconds to start up.
I don't even care, totally
worth it, absolutely worth it.
You should be stopping your
production-grade applications
and updating them with
[INAUDIBLE] right now.
Well my friend--
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
JOSH LONG: I think we're
just about out of time.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, but we do have
a few last slides that we got.
So let's take a look at--
let's go back-- what did you
have the thing right here.
JOSH LONG: There we are.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
So we went through quite
a few things today.
JOSH LONG: A few.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, just a few.
There are a number of different
starters you can actually
use, like I said,
configuration storage, logging.
So what we can do is to
correlate your logs directly
with Trace as well.
All of these are
fully integrated
with Spring and Spring Boot.
And there are tons of
resources you can use.
We have the project home
page, the documentation,
the source coding examples.
We got short code lab.
We got long code lab.
We have a boot camp
tomorrow as well.
You are welcome to join.
And of course, we
have other things
from project Riff and
Josh's favorite place
after production, which is?
JOSH LONG: Start.Spring.io
We'll take any questions.
Thank you so much.
RAY TSANG: Thanks
for being here.
Thank you.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]